[Music]
in zero empathy news it's really but I
can't draw for [ __ ] major was fired
after telling an employee that her son's
poor health is no reason to miss work Oh
Sam
cold-blooded what was the poor health
because some moms think a cough is like
that was true
how about crazy being on life support ah
that's it what kind of work does she do
she works at this place gassy
yeah casting a gas station mm-hmm I bet
you the owner is of a different country
what country your old country Joe well
country job one outside of America oh oh
and he spent most of his time in life
there and then came to America that's
true women could discriminate to
equality all right so this gas station
manager was actually fired after this
whole interaction here so crystal she
was telling her manager that her 18 year
old son was rushed to the hospital after
his temperature spiked to 104 degrees
and he had low oxygen and so she had her
14 year old daughter contact the boss to
let her know that she won't be able to
make it to work so this is crystal she
needs a new haircut use the one that got
perhaps that I got fired by her this is
the mom just came so crispy mom oh I
thought the manager got fired for how
she treated her oh I see this is her son
he had to go to the hospital yeah he was
put on life support and so this is the
exchange so my son is on life support
and I tell my boss 48 hours before I am
to work again that I will not be able to
work until my son is off of life support
and this is what she tells me
oh she she Joe she Joe do you want to be
a manager do you crystal I would like to
be the manager all right so there's
crystal hi Don this is crystal I'm just
letting you know my son is still on life
support so until he is out of the bat I
will not be able to make it to work I
can let you know as he starts to get
better so that way I can return to work
with no problems
that isn't how we do things so I accept
that you're quitting okay so how do we
do things when my child is on life
support I never said I was quitting so I
take it that you're firing me if you
can't come to work that's you quitting
no that's not I'm letting you know I
can't come to work due to my child's
life on the line I'm letting you know
ahead of time I will not get into with
you on here but I've been more than
accommodating during this allowing
schedule changes and such there is no
reason you can't work and I will not
tolerate drama and of Converse promise
see if you aren't there to work your
shift tomorrow then I will take it that
you have quit okay this is not an eye
doctors appointment or a dentist's
appointment this is my child's life
we're talking about he's on life support
okay I will be in contact with corporate
I will I never quit my job and you can't
work because questionmark
too much drama here's the number for the
corporate okay and then crystal says
would you be able to go would you be
able to go to work and function if your
child was on life support I don't know
if I'm coming or going a night and I
expect me to work yes I would I still
have bills to pay and something keep me
busy and occupied we don't just get to
come and go as we please at folk I have
tomorrow and Monday covered your son is
in the best place he can be I have a
store to run and that's my focus whoa
man who is this person evil this person
is done and maybe that's how she was
treated as a child like you need to you
know it doesn't matter if you're sick if
you're dying if your leg is falling off
you need to come to work she's
identified as dawn I don't have a last
name do we have a picture
wait dawn is the good Johnson No Oh does
the bad dawn is the manager crystal is a
mom I wanted to see the dawn yeah
there's nothing
we don't like dawn once he dawn we want
a roast on yeah we want a roaster that's
what we do here are just kidding
we got a roast the bad person and then
sometimes we roast a good person on that
too fun we can't help it
everyone's row stable mm-hmm everyone is
a big opportunity roasting yes it's your
fault you took a weird picture or it's
your fault that you're ugly what's your
parents fault right almost fault it is
me I mean I mean it was a fault
halt just right thank you for I agree
yeah you got Navajo it helps us
understand how he arraignment yeah I was
like [ __ ] that subject cuz I'm moving on
to the next so how can I get my revenge
on what can I do - yeah write my
congressman know like is uh is she not
the [ __ ] lawsuit God cuz I hope she
do well they did fire her she's treating
this gas station job like his life or
death yeah you know we have [ __ ]
people that are waiting I'm right they
need to bite their Lay's potato chip
nobody's gonna ring them up but what if
it's one of those big gas stations like
those truck rest stops whether it's like
24 pumps man it's the big one you know
the kind that also has Slurpees and
coffee dude that shoe that we were in at
Florida remember that one the huge yeah
you should go to buggies in tech that is
Bucky's is who that's just like a
grocery store gas station so yeah maybe
the soil places like that but still yeah
but there's so many employees and though
one person ran you know yeah you know
what I'm thinking is what I'm thinking
all right okay what do you think okay
what do we do a [ __ ] its mouth false
okay this is nothing okay all right this
is what I'm thinking that's a really
mean manager but what if what if she's a
habitual wolf crier
you don't say okay I see someone that's
always like mm I got an elbow injury I
got a dis I'm going into I got
salmonella
my Tesla crash you know Honda Element
breaking down yeah emergency emergency
that's why she called it drama she's
like don't give me this drama no more no
more drama oh yeah
too much but in this this time it
actually her song well I mean the
company the corporate office did say
that they investigated this so I'm sure
if she did have a reason act that way
and I just wanted to make her the back
now you're right devil's advocate I know
yeah well I'll tell you this though you
know what's really [ __ ] up okay so I
used to work in shipping and logistics
right so warehouse guys the cheapest way
to get warehouse guys guys just grab
boxes pick [ __ ] whatever is day labor
they day labor companies but they're
legit day laborers cuz like there's like
agencies that basically send guys over
if you need five hours of work or
whatever guys like a tenant job yeah
it's a temp job yeah it's a temp agency
yeah here's the thing though what sucks
is we'll have tap guys working for us
for months right and if they get like
sick or something and they can't come in
when we went when we need them to then
they'll they'll call and say we want
another guy we don't like this guy
oh really yeah and a lot of guys they do
temp agencies because they want to prove
themselves and then they go alright
maybe after a year or two I work hard
enough they'll hire me doesn't happen
just game taking advantage of yeah cuz
once it's too costly to hire people once
you hire them you have to like
yeah I was four years per diem and I've
lost oh four years
Wow years oh my god why did it get you
you know Jesus but it's also like the
laws fault too because they're scared if
you become an employee then you can
start suing than you could do oh yeah so
it's like it's either you're really
shitty or really [ __ ] like I don't
know that's when they passed that whole
like yeah employers have to give health
insurance and stuff and people just
started hiring anyone that was full-time
and like you can only only hired
part-time people because they couldn't
afford the health insurance for
everybody it's crazy it has to be a
balance between it's not fair so what do
we do Joe I don't know how do we fix it
Joe Marlene I think I think this is what
we do ya get a bunch of smart fair
people to do all the work and
decision-making for us how do we hire
them day laborer a dictators Roundtable
I think we should vote and then vote the
fair nice people and then we live under
their authority yeah I like it yeah yeah
yeah it's never been done it's never
been this is the next level we're doing
right this time yeah this time is gonna
be different yeah we'll get really good
people who aren't corrupt yeah yeah
and what we should do the fairest of the
fair and everyone gets paid the same and
identical identical no matter how much
work you do
that's right all way Jose that no matter
what everyone's working the same amount
of hard yes because I don't matter what
job you have you're working the same
amount of time not hard you know be cool
if politicians got paid based on how
effective their work was oh yeah
no vehicle if politicians had to live in
the district districts where they're
from that'd be tight I mean we didn't
just get to move to Washington live in
some $150,000 apartment yeah that's how
it used to be doesn't it to live in your
dresser there's hell of mayors that
don't even live in their own say exactly
they live out of their district yeah cuz
they live in a richer part of I thought
you have to live in your [ __ ] area
this Congress almost so many Congress
people order to live their own district
you live like in the rich area wherever
outlying area and then they make laws
that don't even affect them at all I
don't even see the daily life anymore
I only think it's fair if cops don't
live in the same city that they patrol
because it's dangerous for them oh that
makes some tension yeah but then other
other other people like I mean like
judges cops or whatever I think that's
fair but then politicians man you got to
know how many potholes we have
[ __ ] because that's your job
yeah you're a public servant you should
know yeah oh and then being able to also
invest in companies that you also give
special sweetheart deals to should be
not allowed whatsoever all these cats
make it a hundred G's a year right in
Congress they leave Congress or like 20
years in Congress they're worth 30
million dollars how do you figure that
one out
the sweetest [ __ ] gig on earth it's
on the street hardest drink pull
absolutely [ __ ] corruption man
everywhere corrupt sure we would do it
right we would do it the good because we
would get good people mm-hmm I would
purge them yeah I will purge them of
corruption and replace it with my
friends me too yeah only my friends cuz
I could trust my friends only my closest
friends just all everyone here JK
people's oh thanks but you know what's
the problem is I don't know if any of us
know how to run [ __ ] at all so that's
the problem we're gonna find out yeah
cuz I rather I
they're not run I would fill it with
kitties okay I disagree with it you just
pet a kitty and then if they get too old
you kind of you I want to fellow a dog I
want to know the cats and dogs are gonna
fight now and then we'll have team cats
and key team got dog I think we should
ban all pets is better it's been no
crazy argument we're gonna be awful see
we gotta figure out somethin guy it's
the dog people's fault let's just move
away from this little shake place we
made with no pets
[Music]